come on mr. Tatem package fresh I'm
gonna need a minute alone right for the
gonorrhea they arrest Channing but you
have in your hands what you have been
searching for we never gave up the quest
for our favorite forgotten Romanian
television show perhaps now you will
find some level of peace I know I right
need a VCR go bring some vodka with the
VCR when you bring it back you don't
become a good countenance by going or
memorizing the manifesto
[Music]
do do it Amazon Studios and a 24 bring
new comrade detective
story Channing Tatum
as Detective Gregor angle
Joseph gordon-levitt a detective Joseph
but you and Nick Offerman as the captain
separately we're like this but together
we're fists fists
boug raspy bringing drugs into this
country so you can turn our brothers and
sisters into attic watch the streets of
Bucharest to look like the streets of
Detroit so Bob when you hear what the
people is murdered
we'll do whatever is a lab to fight an
evil empire Todd what you know about
Nikita take off the net
ah the Cold War risen questions he was
my lawyer
you
proclaim what's your secret I always bet
on right
Konrad detected an Amazon Prime member
exclusive
you
you